the LGBTQA IP Thank You number two
community which was which was birthed
from intersectional feminism is now
responsible for women getting the kicked
out of them a transgender Texas wrestler
just one's his second high school title
so here's my question of the day before
we move on is do you think that this is
a fringe issue that won't affect many or
do you think that this trans equivalency
with women is actually starting to
really harm women as we're seeing in
sports do you think that that's a
microcosm you're seeing that at large
the LGBTQIA IP movement I know it's sort
of deconstruct cyl well the fundamental
premise of feminism but let's remove
that do you think it's starting to hurt
women at large
um I think so I think this is an example
so this is Mark bags a senior from ulis
Trinity High School near Dallas is in
the process of transitioning from female
to male and taking low dose of
testosterone just entered a high school
wrestling tournament with an undefeated
record and surprise one picture says a
thousand words so supporters have called
Briggs brave and beautiful dismissing
her detractors as doctors scientists and
the rest let's do this compare the
average testosterone level of a male
versus female so like let's compare them
and then compare them an anabolic spirit
so for male the mid range test level
between 25 and 30 years is about 670
here that that's free that's total
testosterone not free to up testosterone
is measured by nanograms per deciliter
so this is a number when you hear the
number 670 I'm gonna use numbers that
are pretty consistent for comparison you
can look it up afterwards
so uh when it comes to steroids when it
comes to injected testosterone it varies
wildly studies though have been
conducted officially with men injecting
600 milligrams per week okay which
results in testosterone levels of about
two thousand three hundred and fifty and
some change okay that's higher so that
means that are doping athlete a male
athlete versus another male athlete
might have something like a three and a
half times testosterone advantage of a
natural athlete now here's what's
important obviously testosterone but you
can see this a lot with growth hormone
with luteinizing hormone hormones across
the board it determines not only your
ability to recover also
neurotransmitters also how your bones
develop these are very important that's
why people pay a lot of money fall so if
your goal yes
uh it amplifies it the goal of
transgender hormone replacement
therapies to get women into the normal
range of males okay so uh this actually
comes to us from is this from or is it
from sent Boston University Boston
University okay
target practice a practical target for
momentarily for transgender men female
to male that's where you see FTM in case
you see a lot is it to increase
testosterone levels to the normal male
physiological they're trying to get it
to at 600 range okay three hundred
thousand so let's normal marrow range
670 you're trying to get a woman to six
seventy and you're allowing them to
compete against other women mid range
for females without form on replacement
therapy is around forty to forty June
immigrants were definitely this means
that a female to male transgender could
have roughly a seven to twenty three
times
the testosterone advantage of a normal
woman much take the most steroid it out
freak it could possibly imagine out in a
thong in the mr. Olympia stage he does
not even enjoy a fraction of the
hormonal advantage over his male
counterparts that a male enjoys over a
female period let alone a female on
hormone replacement therapy and it's
more important because here's think even
once you stop the hormones if you've had
these during your developing stages it
stays with you again your bones your
muscles how they develop you start to
lose it you start to atrophy but think
these people male to female they've
developed as a man their entire life
with 20-plus times the amount of
hormones that a woman would have and
then all of a sudden they say you know
what Your Honor I would like to be a I
think I'm a woman now and I'd like to be
free to beat up women and they say okay
we don't want a douche this is not the
first time this has happened
he'll say this is not an extreme example
we talked about Fallon Fox a man beating
up a woman let's roll this clip not cage
here as you can see very much it's not
hyper ly technical it looks like what
you would expect a domestic dispute
would look like it looks like a man
beating up a woman just look just
picking it up and just smash
male-to-female transgender weightlifter
won gold that's one then you had a male
to female transgender
won their second sprinting title
recently and of course had a cyclist who
won the was a tour to Arizona toward
Tucson or to do some song on the flip
side there are well there are a few
examples of female to males
continue to compete women's teams and
divisions this happened in Texas because
they don't allow you to turn
so Kylie alums female-to-male who
continue to playing women's NCAA
basketball have been taken in
testosterone for a long time
there aren't many examples of that okay
but that does happen so you have male
the female they compete in female sports
and then female to male still compete in
female sports because when females go to
male sports they don't do so well so I
don't hear about it a whole lot take for
example the famous female to male
transgender I think was a Kris Kris
Mosley the do athlete was worried about
competing because at these anti-trans
laws now you plays 37 so much trailer
Baylor world-renowned female to male
transgender swimmer ranked 83rd at the
most readings recent so you know it's
not but your biology isn't bigoted just
not that good you were talking about the
parents this wrestling champion
I find this funny that the person that's
female to male the Z I don't want to I
don't want this to get banned off of
YouTube by the way no sorry by the way
hit the notification bell if you're
subscribed because this definitely won't
show up in your feet the mom begs mother
said he has so much respect for all the
girls he wrestles first off hold on Sven
come back to me we'll bring a back up
that overlay okay mom when you say about
your son girl what do you say about your
girl son he has so much respect for all
the girls he wrestles how much strength
does it take for you to not blow your
own head off my son has all the respect
in the world for all the girls out of
whom he beats the ever-loving sheep it's
obvious he does it with respect so ok
bring it back up
Angela McNew look if the mother people
think Mac has been beating up on girls
the girls he wrestles with they are
pretty tough it has more to do with
skill and discipline and strength it has
to do with strength and steroids don't
forget it has to do with steroids and
gigantic levels of testosterone
it's just technique right he has all the
respect for the ladies because they used
to be one I don't know your tough chick
I have all I have all the respect for
you in the world as an independent woman
I'll check
or for a girl going out wrestling so it
is strike two uppercut and you know what
they'll try and sable want you just let
them compete as a male this person
doesn't necessarily want to compete is
another thing when you look at when they
do have the option they try and wiggle
into as we see there are far more
examples of female to male transgender
still competing as females and there are
competing as males and then of course
all males to females compete as females
if you have two cups of coffee the
Russians are going to take it right
afterward yeah you test positive in the
Olympics yes there's a certain threshold
for caffeine right right but with a girl
injecting testosterone directly into her
ass cheek however the rulebook gets a
little bit murky lured with razor and
this is done in the jet the name of
gender equality but it's it's always
this is the thing and we talking about
this at large it's always the biological
females that suffer if you let people
switch genders you end up with male the
female transgenders they compete in they
crush women if you don't let the athlete
switch genders but still allow them to
compete while injecting testosterone the
doping women them women they end up
crushing the women as you see in the
wrestling competition here on the flip
side if you're logically ideologically
consistent and you force the female to
male athletes to compete with men
we'll have record level of sporting
deaths that you've never seen before
sounds like there's not a win-win
there's no win it's almost as though put
taking women and putting them on the
football field with men there's no way
you're winning that situation by that
same token it's almost as though if you
were to take that woman injector full of
male hormones and let her compete
against women there's also no winning
it's a lose lose lose but here's the
deal
it's only a lose lose lose for women we
don't really care a transgender woman
come into our sport it's kind of cute no
I said come get out of here we brush
them aside and we compete with the real
men LGBTQA IP thank you number two
community which was which was birthed
from intersectional feminism is now
responsible for women gettin the kicked
out of them not figuratively literally
hey did you like this video of course
you did let's there's something wrong
with you in which case you can comment
below what's your problem with this
video we want to hear from you and we
promise you 100% I give you my word as
my bond will answer every sin
negative comment for those who are
normal you can leave a thumbs up and
subscribe